As Star Trek: The Next Generation
concluded its final episode in 1994,
many fans were left wanting more. So why
was it gone before its time seemed up?
Not only had the series been a massive hit, but
it was more profitable than most TV shows at the
time. Trekkies clamored for comic books,
action figures, novels, and video games…
"Only you can make the life or death
decisions required of a Starfleet officer."
…so it seemed like a strange decision to just
end one of the most popular
and profitable shows on TV.
All was not lost, however. As The New York Times
reported of the series finale in July 1994,
franchises were a big deal in Hollywood, and
Paramount wasn't about to take its eye off the
prize, even after the end of the series. As
the adventures of Jean-Luc Picard wound down,
Star Trek: Deep Space Nine was launched,
with Star Trek: Voyager close on the horizon.
Meanwhile, the cast of The Original Series,
led by William Shatner and Leonard Nimoy,
still hung on. They'd been starring in feature
films as recently as 1991, but they were aging,
and the decades-old franchise needed a
constant infusion of new blood to keep afloat.
In 1994, the cast of The Next Generation was
still made up of the youngest established
crew of the franchise. Deep Space
Nine was still finding its feet,
and Paramount wanted to start making movies with a
familiar cast at the helm. That meant freeing the
Next Generation cast from their television
obligations. The feature film Star Trek:
Generations debuted in 1994, only months after
the end of the series, officially passing the
feature film torch from Shatner's James
Kirk to Patrick Stewart's Jean-Luc Picard.
The crew of the Enterprise-D would explosively
destroy their starship in the same movie,
ceremoniously ending their connection to
the small screen. With the new Enterprise-E,
they continued to star in Star
Trek movies until Star Trek:
Nemesis in 2002. Despite occasional cameos
throughout the franchise, the cast of The Next
Generation wouldn't truly reunite until almost
20 years later, for the series Star Trek: Picard.
Another, more obscure reason for the cancellation
of Next Generation had to do with the way network
television operated in the pre-streaming age.
At the time, Paramount was selling the show
directly to local stations, an unusual
move that had paid off well. Ultimately,
the strategy couldn't last forever due to
airtime limitations; stations that bought
the show were required to buy rights to reruns,
and to air each episode as many as seven times.
As the number of episodes grew with each season,
stations that purchased Next Generation would be
filling an increasing number of their limited
slots with old episodes, and there was no such
thing as Netflix for them to offload all that
content without broadcast time restrictions.
By then, profitability was on a downward
trend. As the series grew in size,
stations were less willing to pay top dollar
for new episodes. Meanwhile, the main cast of
a long-running series traditionally had regular
pay raises built into their contracts, and Next
Generation was no exception. The cast was getting
paid more as the show itself made less money.
To this day, Star Trek: The Next Generation
remains a high water mark for many Star Trek
fans. It's enjoying a healthy second
life on streaming and in syndication,
where it continues to be appreciated
by those whose dreams boldly go where
no one has gone before. And, although it
concluded with some unresolved plotlines…
"My name is Barash."
…many would be resolved in Star Trek: Picard,
and most fans agree that the
series ended at the right time.